mercredi 23 mars journée célébration ali
panama du plateau de saclay depuis le
1er mars cette plateforme de recherche
européenne dédiée à l'étude des
matériaux anciens est devenu partenaire
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin
pour l'occasion le secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur a
fait la visite du laboratoire un moyen
de mettre à l'honneur le domaine méconnu
des sciences du patrimoine pour nous
c'était très important de recevoir la
visite
évidemment du ministre monsieur thierry
mandon parce que c'était une manière de
reconnaître le travail accompli depuis
maintenant plusieurs années
le fait qu'il soit venu qui se sont
engagés personnellement ça montre à quel
point ce qu'on essaye de bâtir à lui
mais est-ce qu au plateau de saclay plus
généralement en ile de france dans cette
thématique là c'est quelque chose qui a
vocation est de rayonnement
international dans notre domaine
la participation de l'université comme
versailles saint quentin donne cette
garantie là le fait que ça va devenir
une matière à part entière que des
étudiants seront dirigés vers des études
de recherche dans ces domaines là et
donc sa garantie la durabilité des
perspectives scientifiques
une vingtaine de scientifiques français
et étrangers travaillent dans cette
infrastructure
lors de la visite ils ont pu échanger
avec thierry mandon sur leurs recherches
ils n'augurait en 2013 par le cnrs et le
ministère de la culture libanais m'a
permet de recueillir de précieuses
informations sur notre histoire grâce à
des techniques les avancées ça permet
d'approfondir l'étude des matériaux
patrimoniaux matériaux paléontologique
archéologique de des collections des
musées d'en comprendre les modes de
fabrication l'origine et les processus
d'altération c'était une très bonne
chose de formaliser ce partenariat qui
va nous permettre de développer de
nouveaux projets nous on va apporter des
moyens humains probablement aussi à peu
financés au laboratoire un partenariat
qui permettra d'amener de la recherche
universitaire et de la formation au sein
du laboratoire pour lui vs q c'est une
preuve de sa détermination à s'ouvrir
sur la scène internationale